um and so i'm curious like how you guys
feel about submission
my initial thought when i saw that video
was like
you know you do you but that's not for
me you know but that's for someone by
yeah what do you mean it's not for you
why why is it not for you i mean because
different strokes for different folks if
she chooses to submit and that's who she
wants to be then that's so you have a
problem with submission
um
[Music]
no
in my own life i'm i wouldn't say i'm
much of a submissive girl so for me that
wouldn't be how i would choose to live
my life but if she wants to do that then
she don't want to get married
and be being submissive i i don't think
that me not being submissive is going to
stop me from getting married i think it
makes it harder because the the
masculine men like they want to lead
typically yeah and so if you're like so
when you're submitting you're saying
like i trust you with the big decisions
i trust you to lead yeah and so i think
unless you would prefer a guy that
follows
which
to me as a woman is like a turn off
it's not a case that i don't want to
submit by the way it's probably just a
case of i haven't found the right person
i want to submit to well i don't i think
it's kind of either you're submissive or
you're not as a person probably not then
yeah that's that's
because because um
like i i don't because to me it being
submissive pairs with the trait
agreeableness yeah and it's it's paired
with like being able to follow someone
um so i think it's more of a personality
trait go on over sorry you just came
well
sorry guys got tagged in there i don't
think you can disagree with the super
chats and then say oh i don't want to be
submissive to my man because think about
this way yeah if i was to say i was
going to be conditionally masculine so
i'm dressed like a girl and say ah yeah
are you saying babes and then i'll be
like wait i can only be masculine when
you make me feel that way
that doesn't make no sense so think
about what you're saying no let me tell
you how i was raised so i grew up in a
house of um
eight girls
one brother he's super young so my dad
always taught us to be like really
independent and i think i've just been
like independent by default and growing
up with that mindset there's nothing
wrong with that and i think that that's
right but at the same time if you're
looking for a man
for most women they want a masculine man
who can hold the fort down
so unless you're willing to submit to a
man
naturally you have to go for the
opposite which is amanda submissive i
think i just hate that word submissive
to be honest with you what does it mean
to you
for me personally i get like some
negative sort of what does it mean
though
it almost feels to
bend
and you know
do whatever he says yeah let your man
have the the reins of the
relationship and
that's what it feels like to me it is
you relinquish control and i don't yeah
i'm a bit of a control freak where you
know
i am i'll be honest i know i am but but
it's interesting because um when i like
i i've talked to
like a lot of black guys follow this
account and a common complaint i hear
with them with black women is they feel
like they can't submit to them
i feel like black women don't want to
submit those yeah
they're afraid that if they submit
that black man is still going to turn
around and uh go for someone in a
different race
and then talk [ __ ] about them i don't
know oh so there's a fear of that yeah i
i i there's that as well because when i
hear submission i feel like what i i'd
never want to do that but from having a
conversation the other day it's kind of
changed my mind on submission it's more
like
like what you were saying allowing a man
to be a man and like walk in his
masculine energy and you being
submissiveness not necessarily you uh
losing all control is sort of like you
being able to sit in your feminine
energy and to be soft and to allow and
accept and then allow the man to lead
and con not to control but like to
direct
have you ever had a guy
um plan a date but make you plan it be
like what do you want to eat yeah where
do you want to go absolutely or have you
had a guy say okay i'm picking you up at
six this is where we're going
be ready this is the dress code which
which one's more attractive the second
one
what's the problem i'm the sort of girl
that likes to pick the restaurant
because i am a control freak like that
oh you want to pick the restaurant
sometimes i'm the sort of friend is that
because it's out of ease
not because it's the better option
i don't know i feel like my mind is
getting more at ease if i get to control
the situation feminine men a little bit
because i just can't imagine a masculine
man like letting that slide to be honest
so it would almost and you're and you're
also saying that maybe i've definitely
been with masculine men i think i've
just like
go put my foot down to be honest with
you come on you put your foot down
you put that away not with me you better
slow down
but but it's a masculine we've been with
guys who i can have my way with very
easily
it is a truly a truly masculine man
isn't going to put up with that
he's just going to be like this is too
much of a headache let me move on to the
next one
especially because there's a lack of
masculinity in the society so the guys
that are actually masculine they get
hella [ __ ] 100
and the thing is because we're applying
gender to the conversation but masculine
and feminine doesn't just exist to like
a heterosexual relationship if you look
at lesbians when you look at gay people
there's always someone who's a top or
bottom or masculine feminine femme stem
there's never two masculine women
there's always a masculine and feminine
so it causes too many arguments
so if you're saying that you're the
agreeable one you're just the one
wearing the trousers of actually
admitting you're the one wearing the
trousers but you're the one steering the
[ __ ] but then also in the context of
interracial relationships you can start
to see now where in some contexts some
conversations where you'd see that black
men deviate
out of
dating black women because if this is
perspective that the average black woman
carries and you're defending that
statement and we're talking about true
masculinity and how men who are
masculine don't want to have to put up
with that it's easy to see how he's
going to be like you know what even if i
like black women i don't want that kind
of headache so i'm gonna go for someone
else who's not to give me that sort of
trouble i wouldn't call it a headache
that's a headache trust me that's
because you're not on the receiving end
of it yeah i actually understand that
like i really understand that
the thing about submission though it's
not something that every woman is born
with like you have to learn and i don't
know if it's the man that teaches you or
the man that you're with and the man
that you choose that teaches you or you
actually have to see that within
yourself i know that in my experience i
had to see that within myself because i
came in this and i wanted to lead
everything like everything
did you have both parents in your home
no i didn't but i had i had my mom and
my stepdad okay and did your stepdad
come in like later or later on yeah and
so i find that a lot of people that
don't naturally know how to submit they
didn't have that example growing up
of like um a masculine father and the
mother following him or if they did
maybe it was kind of one of those like
relationships where the mom is kind of
like blue ball or what do they say live
on youtube
you hit my parents relationship on the
head my mom is very much the